all right so this weekend one of the
biggest valor in tournaments
ever took place the faze clan
invitational
it was a 50 000 event the best teams in
the world were there including the debut
of faze clan's own ballarat roster
but the game's newest character the one
that everyone's been talking about
was nowhere to be seen why because less
than
24 hours before the event was set to
begin
killjoy was effectively banned by riot
from pro play
okay guys before we go on with the rest
of the video i have to let you know to
head on over to twitch.tv
thescore esports when we're done here
hit the follow button and turn
notifications on because we're going
live on the regular
and we've got content on twitch you
can't find anywhere else all right so
last week
act 2 of valorent went live and we got a
new battle pass
new skins tweaks to match making a death
match mode
and a new agent
[Music]
cool there's just one problem killjoy is
kind of busted the second she came out
youtubers were already
filling their timelines with clips that
looked a little
let's say cheeky we're talking hiding
her nanoswarm grenades in terrain we're
talking using all three of her abilities
for disgusting wombo combos that
basically mean the enemy don't get to
play the game
and her turret unintentionally acting
as a wall hack wait
now at first it was tempting at least
for me to think
well isn't this kind of always what
happens when a new agent or
operator or character whatever is
released in a game
i mean people find little broken
exploits they get a hot reddit clip it
gets hotfixed and we all move on with
our lives
after all there was plenty of outcry
about reyes and about reina when she was
released
but it quickly became apparent that this
situation was a little different
why because last wednesday night faze
clan announced that at the request of
riot
killjoy would be disabled for their
valor and invitational
now we did reach out to riot for more
information on why killjoy could quote
negatively impact the competitive
integrity of this weekend's tournament
but unfortunately as of the filming of
this video we haven't heard anything
back
so i talked to fps commentator van silly
who worked the phaseclan invitational
and he told me that he figures the
request from riot to disable killjoy
was a combination of both the bugs and
exploits that people have been finding
and problems with her
actual kit you know you saw all the
posts that came out before
killjoy came out on that tuesday
everybody was already like rah-rah-rah
i'm not too sure how killjoy's gonna be
in the meta
everybody's actually talking about the
turret the whole time but actually the
turret is wasn't so bad
as soon as it came out it was more like
the rest of her utility
uh in terms of for me the nano swarm and
her ultimate which is the the lockdown i
think it's a little bit overpowered
and i think i think um there was already
ways from abusing those abilities
without really
um discovering bugs and already there
there was already bugs that were found
right so i think
it only made sense to stress tests and
make sure that we took the agent out so
it doesn't break the
like the competitive nature of that
tournament so at least for me i think it
made a lot of sense i think for a lot of
the players they were really happy about
that too
uh just because they had no no days to
prepare so
it made sense in that way vancilly told
me that while a lot of attention has
been paid to killjoy's turret
and her ult it's really the nano swarm
grenades that are the problem
now if you haven't played valorent in
the last week the nanoswarm grenade
is something that killjoy can throw that
detonates on command
not on a timer or by proximity
is invisible until it goes off and she
gets
two of them per round it's basically a
remote control molly
times two so when and how are we going
to see killjoy actually used in pro play
well vancilly for one thinks that fixes
are coming
soon and we won't have to wait until the
next scheduled update by riot
i definitely think there's gonna be a
hotfix coming up i mean if it's already
been announced by wright
um two days before the phase
invitational and it said guys
this is on us like they tweeted this out
they said guys it's on us
just to maintain the competitive
integrity we decided not to
add killjoy into tournament play for the
upcoming phase invitational which
just passed last weekend so that means
they realize that it's not only bugs
that are really breaking the agent right
now for killjoy
but there are certain tweaks that needs
to be done so i think knowing right
and knowing how they listen to the
community are very good with
communication with the
with the community um i expect more of a
hot fix than
than a change on a different act or a
chapter now don't get me wrong here guys
it is a good thing
that riot and their valorette team came
out sort of owned up to their mistake
and
asked that killjoy be disabled for this
tournament
sure it's a little disappointing for
those of us who really wanted to see
what the pros could do with killjoy
but banning her effectively goes a long
way to keeping the competitive integrity
of an esport that is very much still in
its formative stages
for those of us who are fans of
counter-strike it is a refreshing change
from the valve approach
of oh is this thing broken we'll fix it
in
eight months looking at you og it's been
so long hasn't it's day seven and they
still don't know that he's one of
one of them and they're gonna line up oh
my god they all it comes through
beautifully
triple for him and he's gonna close it
out a wonderful ace here
now killjoy wasn't the only hiccup for
act two's release
some people are really disappointed in
the death match mode that riot pushed
which by the way is essential to any
competitive fps that takes itself
seriously
so what's the problem well let's be
honest here ballarat's death match is
less of a live
practice arena and more of a pointless
game mode all on its own
uh just some tweaks again i think it's
just the fact that you're able to see
everybody that's on a blip on a radar
the whole aspect of death match is not
trying to win the death match it's
trying to improve your skill
and to improve your skill it's more
about the fire fights than anything else
so uh how how to land those head shots
how
how to flick and actually land those
headshots practicing your ad mechanics
to be able to uh to shoot accurately
get those bursts practicing your sprays
things like that uh
it's within a six minute timer or 30
kills sometimes it's
it's not enough make it unlimited uh
make it so that you could just really
like okay i'm ready i'm warmed up i want
to go play ranked
just leave the server not get penalized
by any of that either
uh and i think that would be a great
start at least for for the deathmatch
aspect of valorum and one more thing
if we're actually able to play
deathmatch while we are
waiting for a queue even better i don't
know if that's doable but that would be
great to have
now let's jump back to killjoy for just
a second here because there is one more
elephant in the room
when it comes to that character and that
is her actual design
and what it says about the intentions of
riot for the future
of valorant see when killjoy's kit was
first revealed
some people were freaking out
particularly about her turret
not because it's op or anything in fact
it's actually the
least scary of all her abilities but
because
some people felt it betrayed what we
were told
valorent was supposed to be it's pretty
misleading
and pretty hypocritical maybe is the
word for them when the game was
when the game came out in the actual
beta
sorry before the game was even in beta
when the game was in alpha
they came out and they they very
publicly said exactly
what um my chat is spamming right now
which is
to be clear in project a shooting
matters you don't kill with abilities
abilities create tactical opportunities
to take the right shot
characters have abilities that augment
their gun play
instead of fighting directly with their
abilities the question arises
valorent was supposed to be like cs go
but if we keep getting agents like
killjoy
in a year or two are we looking at
something more like overwatch
well i asked van silly and he said it's
hardly time
to hit the panic button just yet you
have to take that with a grain of salt i
think sometimes when
you know you're you're talking on the
spot and stuff for that too it's like
you're just like
just as i'm telling you we're like kind
of their crafting things at the same
time but we don't really know what's
really happening behind the scenes
so just to have the uh assumption that
we're gonna have agents with shields
or or tanks or something like that i
don't think it's going to happen i don't
think this is going to turn into
like a dps healer support tank kind of
thing like we see in overwatch
i think for riot the the main idea as
they're going to fall back towards the
main um first tweet when it was
announced as project a it's like it's
not about the abilities
it's about the kills and still about
your skills uh with the
with firing a gun okay
i have here a klingon english dictionary
which i got from a used bookstore
and let's look up how to say killjoy in
klingon
there's got to be like 10 klingon words
for kill right
oh i'm looking up the klingon words i
need the english oh my god
kill ho ho
ho that's funny okay joy let's look up
joy
they have no word for joy okay let's
look up happy
happy be happy cook
killjoy in klingon is
busted bro
kapla